Trascrizione: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Il discorso che voglio fare, parto dalle sue origini
è quello relativo a quello che oggi si chiama la fusione fredda.
che nacque circa 22 anni fa,
quando un ricercatore americano, un chimico americano,
asserì di aver prodotto energia <br/>mediante un processo di fusione nucleare,
ottenuto utilizzando il palladio, <br/>che è un metallo,
con il deuterio che è un idrogeno pesante.
Dopo di questo,<br/> molti si misero a lavorare sulla sua scia
e hanno lavorato per 22 anni
senza mai ottenere grandi risultati.
Per quello che mi riguarda,
insieme ad un amico dell'università di Siena
decidemmo di lavorare allo stesso modo
utilizzando però l'idrogeno e il nichel
e ottenemmo un certo numero di risultati,
cioè produzione di energia <br/>da interazioni tra l'idrogeno e il nichel.
In seguito, ho ricominciato a lavorare,
dopo aver interrotto i lavori precedenti;
con l'Ingegner Rossi e abbiamo cominciato <br/>a lavorare sulla stessa strada,
cioè costruire sistemi che permettono di ottenere energia
utilizzando l'idrogeno e il nichel.
Ora quello che si può vedere <br/>sono i risultati di questo lavoro.
C'è la prima immagine?
Questo è uno dei primi esperimenti <br/>fatto insieme all'Ingegner Rossi.
Vedete a destra <br/>c'è un secchiello rosso che contiene acqua
nel quale sono immersi dei materiali.
A sinistra c'è la bombola di idrogeno
che venne utilizzata <br/>per introdurre l'idrogeno in questa capsula,
dove avevamo messo anche il nichel.
Scaldandoli insieme, nichel e idrogeno,
venne prodotta dell'energia
e come risultato si ottenne il riscaldamento dell'acqua.
L'esperimento è ovviamente molto rozzo,
perché non valeva la pena, <br/>per questo esperimento,
costruire degli oggetti raffinati.
Questo è l'esperimento successivo;
questa volta invece del secchiello d'acqua
c'è quella specie di ciambella sulla destra
nella quale circola dell'acqua
e nella quale si trova la capsula
contenente il nichel e l'idrogeno.
Il tubo a destra, <br/>che si vede in basso a destra
è quello che porta l'idrogeno;
al centro c'è una bombola di idrogeno
e in questo modo ottenemmo conferma
ai dati dell'esperimento precedente,
con un sistema più pulito del precedente.
La terza immagine, ecco,
è ancora un terzo metodo per effettuare le misure.
Questa volta c'è un circuito chiuso;
si vede bene in fondo a destra il tubo,
nel quale è inserito quel cilindro, <br/>sempre sulla destra;
nel tubo circola dell'acqua.
In questo cilindro <br/>avviene il processo di riscaldamento
che è una reazione nucleare fra il nichel e l'idrogeno
e quello che si è osservato sperimentalmente
è la differenza di temperatura <br/>fra i due estremi del cilindro.
Quindi i tre esperimenti hanno confermato
che il sistema è effettivamente in grado <br/>di produrre energia
sotto forma termica,
cioè abbiamo ottenuto il riscaldamento dell'acqua.
Questo è uno degli ultimi oggetti <br/>costruito dall'Ingegner Rossi,
che prende il nome di E-Cat,
dove Cat è un'abbreviazione di catalizzatore,
che viene utilizzato normalmente e attualmente
per fare esperimenti
nei quali si utilizza ancora una volta
la reazione fra il nichel e l'idrogeno
per produrre calore.
E questo calore prodotto <br/>viene messo in evidenza
mediante il riscaldamento di acqua
con dispositivi vari di cui questo è uno degli esempi.
Questo è il prossimo prodotto <br/>costruito dall'Ingegner Rossi
che è sempre basato sullo stesso processo.
E' una specie di vagone ferroviario;
qui non si vede <br/>che ha le dimensioni del vagone ferroviario.
All'interno si vedono delle scatole,
ciascuna delle quali è un generatore
che produce gli stessi effetti <br/>che ho descritto prima.
Facendo lavorare insieme tutti questi elementi
si dovrebbe avere come risultato <br/>una potenza prodotta
pari a un milione di watt.
Non è ancora stato messo in funzione con tutti i generatori,
lo sarà entro questo mese.
A questo punto, chiaramente, <br/>il discorso cambia dimensioni.
Ma in realtà ciascuna di quelle scatole che si vedono
è simile ai vecchi generatori
dove si utilizza la reazione idrogeno-nichel
per ottenere calore.
Queste è chiaramente una reazione nucleare,
tant'è che negli esperimenti che noi abbiamo condotto,
ormai li facciamo da circa due anni, un anno e mezzo,
non so ricordare esattamente la data di inizio,
alla fine dell'esperimento,
quando si analizza il materiale residuo,
cioè quello che era stato messo nella capsula,
che all'origine era nichel <br/>al quale veniva aggiunto l'idrogeno,
si trova in parte ancora il nichel, <br/>ma in parte anche il rame.
Ora, il rame è l'elemento che nella scala periodica,
segue il nichel, è a fianco del nichel.
E il nucleo di rame differisce dal nucleo di nichel
solo perché ha un protone in più,
è il protone che è stato introdotto,
che è stato catturato dal nichel
nel processo di reazione nucleare.
Quindi questa è un'altra delle prove
che, quando noi affermiamo che si tratta di una reazione nucleare
fra nichel e idrogeno,
non è la nostra un'affermazione di fantasia,
ma abbiamo le prove, perché come risultato
alla fine si forma il rame.
Ora, uno dei problemi che nascono
quando si parla di argomenti di questo tipo
è il problema della sicurezza.
In questo caso la minaccia alla sicurezza
sarebbe la radioattività.
Perché trattandosi di un processo nucleare,
è chiaro che uno si aspetta <br/>che ci sia della radioattività
emessa nel processo.
Questo è vero.
E per fortuna,
questo processo dà origine soltanto a raggi gamma
e non a neutroni.
Devo dire anche che il pericolo dei neutroni,
il rischio dei neutroni, <br/>l'ho sempre messo in evidenza
fin dall'inizio della collaborazione con Rossi.
Rossi ovviamente ha preso le misure opportune
perché se ci fossero stati neutroni,
le cose sarebbero state difficili,
perché i neutroni si possono schermare,
ma non è un problema semplice.
Per fortuna non ci sono neutroni,
ma ci sono i raggi gamma.
Che ci siano i raggi gamma <br/>io l'ho sperimentato direttamente
nei primi esperimenti <br/>che si svolgevano nel laboratorio
che Rossi allora aveva a Bondeno,
perché spesso facevo io <br/>le misure mentre lui continuava
a mandare avanti la sua attività;
e io durante le prime misure <br/>usavo un rivelatore di radioattività,
di radiazione e misuravo i raggi gamma,
non molto pericolosi,
non dosi grandi rispetto alla radioattività naturale,
ma comunque esistenti.
Ed è chiaro che non c'era nessun motivo
di aumentare la radioattività naturale.
Mentre non abbiamo mai osservato neutroni,
che è sempre stata la mia preoccupazione,
perché i neutroni sono difficili da schermare.
Ma non sono mai stati presenti.
Allora, il problema dei raggi gamma
l'abbiamo risolto semplicemente utilizzando
attorno al generatore di energia
dei piccoli spessori di piombo,
i quali hanno la caratteristica
di assorbire i raggi gamma.
Per cui non si corre nessun rischio di radioattività
quando si lavora in questo modo.
Questo è giusto non solo per noi,
ma soprattutto quando ci saranno le applicazioni.
Io penso che a questo punto potrei concludere.
Grazie.
(Applausi)